Arrows are set to fly when Jeremy Renner's
Hawkeye spin-off series hits the Disney+ streaming
platform in 2021, but it turns out there was
originally a very different plan for Marvel's
bow-loving Avenger.
That plan was to give Clint Barton his moment
in the cinematic sun with a feature film in
the vein of the rest of his original Avengers
brethren.
Somewhere along the line, though, Marvel head
honcho Kevin Feige had second thoughts about
continuing Hawkeye's story in a big-screen,
standalone film.
Rather than banking on the one-off Hawkeye
flick that Renner had originally signed on
for, Feige and the Marvel team instead reimagined
the hero's narrative prospects for a small
screen venture, deciding that the Hawkeye
story the MCU needed would actually benefit
from a serialized approach.
The Disney+ series will see Renner's arrow-slinging
archer officially passing the torch to the
next Hawkeye in the form of the comics' fan
favorite character Kate Bishop.
Though no deal has officially been inked for
the coveted role of Kate, Hailee Steinfeld
has been circling the role for months, and
it seems like just a matter of time before
a deal is done.
Although it's plain that a multi-episode serial
will allow for more of a deep dive into Barton's
post-Endgame story than a feature film would
have, Feige was a bit apprehensive about flipping
the plan.
Luckily, it doesn't sound like Renner needed
much convincing about transitioning Hawkeye
from big screen to small.
Renner's Hawkeye has been hanging around the
MCU since that brief cameo in 2011's Thor,
followed by a full appearance in 2012's The
Avengers.
The character has appeared in just three MCU
films since: Avengers: Age of Ultron, Captain
America: Civil War, and Avengers: Endgame.
While Barton has become a fan favorite of
sorts over the course of those films, he's
frequently been relegated to secondary status
among the increasingly crowded Avengers landscape.
"We haven't met yet.
I'm Clint."
"I don't care."
This likely played a big part in Hawkeye's
transition to the small screen.
Of course, if the ultimate goal of Marvel's
Hawkeye series is to see Barton pass the bow
to the next generation, then the series should
also offer an opportunity for MCU fans to
get acquainted with young Kate Bishop.
The inclusion of Bishop in future phases of
the MCU also helps to bolster the rumor that
Feige and company are planning for a Young
Avengers flick at some point in the future.
One other Young Avenger has already been introduced
in the MCU: the now-teenage Cassie Lang, the
daughter of Ant-Man, who in the comics goes
on to be a member of the Young Avengers under
the name Stature.
It's just possible that the Hawkeye series
could set up the formation of this team, although
that is pure speculation at this point.
In fact, it's still a bit too early to tell
just what narrative tack Hawkeye will take,
but it seems likely that we'll be seeing a
modified version of Bishop's origin story.
The character first appeared as a trauma survivor
who beefs up on combat training in the wake
of a brutal attack.
She's thrust into heroic action by happenstance,
coming to the aid of the titular team in Young
Avengers #1.
By the time Bishop took up the Hawkeye mantle
in the comics, Barton had already been killed
off.
Strangely enough, it was Captain America,
by way of Jessica Jones, who officially passed
the Hawkeye code name off to Bishop, so Marvel's
creative team will clearly have to make some
changes when adapting Bishop's story for the
small screen.
That, however, should be a fairly easy task.
Given the wringer that Barton was put through
during the events of Avengers: Endgame, it's
a safe bet that the aging hero will be eager
to pass the bow on to a young apprentice.
Whatever direction Marvel's creative team
choose to go in with Hawkeye, it's clear that
the narrative ground for the series remains
more than fertile.
It's just as clear that fans are beyond excited
to spend a little extra time with Barton;
here's hoping that the excitement extends
to whomever steps into the fray as Bishop.
Hawkeye is expected to debut on Disney+ in
late 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.